hey guys we are back from e3 that's
right not even the cone flu could stop
us and we got a bunch more gaming news
we missed you guys so let's get started
[Music]
hey down how much destiny one did you
play 312 hours
oh my god 312 hours alright well not to
worry as Bungie have said that you could
be eligible for some rewards in destiny
- that's like almost two weeks of my
life just belong in a blog post the
studio explained they're hesitant to
reveal all of the ways destiny - will
acknowledge veteran players but they did
details seven emblems that will carry
over I could have taken a holiday to
Europe in that time Jess that's a few
you've already missed the chance to earn
such as completing a moment of triumph
during Destiny's first year or
completing all eight moments of triumph
during year - why did I just sit down
and write that book I'm always talking
about but I can never seem to find the
time you can still claim at least three
of the emblems there young wolf for
reaching rank - in the age of triumph
record book Saladin's pride for reaching
rank 7 and the loss color for achieving
a grimoire score of over 5,000 not
that's it I'm never wasting time again
this is the last straw I'm gonna start
living that's be quick give the cutoff
for earning those is August the first a
bitter in stores just what's your
favorite Beatles song strawberry fields
forever okay I really need you to say
baby you can drive my car because Final
Fantasy 15 is taking off the guardrails
and you can now drive that car any way
you want ahead of the games next DLC
chapter episode prompt dough square has
released a new update that weighs in at
a mighty eight point six five gigabytes
the off-roading feature comes in the
form of the regalia type D customization
option which basically transforms your
wheels into a monster truck if that
sounds good to you get up Cindy at the
Hammerhead service station and she'll
sort you out aside from that addition
the patch also adds new music from the
upcoming DLC episode which you'll be
able to listen to on your car radio as
well as various bug fixes you don't
listen to those it's just in the patch
if it's really the deal see you're
excited for you seriously don't have
long to wait as it's true out tomorrow
Nintendo are breaking the long-standing
tradition of only releasing brand new
things by bringing out
senesce classic edition I'm pretty sure
I intend I just hit a right on their
existing franchises that was the joke
yeah we had a pretty good idea this one
would be on the way but now it's 100%
real confirmed and maybe we can actually
get a look into buying this one before
they're all gone
Nintendo hasn't said specifically how
many units will be on the market but
they have said it'll be significantly
more than the number of NES classic
Edition consoles that said Nintendo will
only be shipping the consoles between
September and the end of 2017 the SNES
classic edition launches on September 29
in the United States and Europe and will
come with a total of 21 games including
earthbound Donkey Kong Country The
Legend of Zelda a Link to the Past and
Super Mario well there's some good stuff
in there there's some really good stuff
you can check out the full list of games
in our story on site which happens to
include starfox to that game that was
famously never released as saying yes
classic features an HDMI output and it
looks like a mini SNES it comes with two
controllers in the box and will run you
80 bucks a nice games what news for
today and I bet you never guessed that
we're grappling with horrific jet lag
thanks so much for joining us once again
and you will see our faces tomorrow so
come join us there again you'll see them
again tomorrow come join us in I don't
like them over here